Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman
show, I'm Farron Cousins once again
sitting in for David Pakman, we've
got a wonderful show coming up today.
Got to talk a little bit about the Jan. six
committee. More news on Joe Manchin and of course,
Donald Trump and Bill O'Reilly's history tour,
where Trump got in a bit of trouble with his
audience for admitting he had been vaccinated.
So let's jump right in. Let's start actually
with Donald Trump and Bill O'Reilly during their
history tour that was in Texas this past weekend.
Bill O'Reilly talked to Donald Trump about
the vaccines, and Trump encouraged the crowd.
Take credit for it. Don't miss this opportunity.
But it was when Bill O'Reilly admitted he had been
vaccinated, and then Trump admitted
he had been vaccinated and boasted
that the crowd turned against them. Here it is.
Take a look at this entire clip of what happened.
Speaker 2: But look, we did something that
was historic. We saved tens of millions of
lives worldwide. We together, all of us. Not
me. We we got a vaccine done. Three vaccines
done and tremendous therapeutics like Regeneron
and other things that have saved a lot of lives.
We got a vaccine done in less than nine
months that was supposed to take from
five to 12 years because of that vaccine, because
of that vaccine. Millions and millions of people,
I think this would have been the Spanish flu
of 1917, where up to a hundred million people
died. This was going to ravage the country far
beyond what it is right now. Take credit for it.
Take credit for it's a great what we've done is
historic. Don't let them take away. Don't take
it away from ourselves. You're playing that.
You're playing right into their hands when you
sort of like, Oh, the vaccine, if you don't want
to take it, you shouldn't be forced to take it.
No mandates. But take credit because we saved
tens of millions of lives. Take credit. Don't
let them take that away from you. OK, so the
president made. Do you agree with that right?
Both the president and I are
vaccinated. You get the booster.
Yes, I got it too. OK, so on doubt da da da da
DA Nang, that's always a very tiny group of.
Speaker 1: All right. So they've
both gotten their booster shots. And
the audience wasn't too thrilled with that. But as
Trump said, don't worry, it's just a small group
of people over here. All right. Here's the thing.
Most of what Trump said there, I'm OK with, right?
Actually encouraging people like you should get
the vaccine, and then of course, the UN does
it by saying, but if you don't want to get it,
you shouldn't be forced to, you know, mandates.
OK, see, you kind of lost it there, but I
understand you got to play to your base.
But think about this, and I've actually
mentioned this all throughout this year,
when vaccines became readily available, you didn't
have to get on waiting lists. Yet there's still
so much hesitancy within the Republican Party
itself. Trump could have been doing this months
ago with these exact same talking points, right?
Coming out saying, Listen, trust it. I have mine.
This was developed while I was president. You guys
love me, right? So if you love me, get yourself
vaccinated. And then of course, he could have done
the same thing once boosters became recommended,
but he didn't. In fact, you can tell from that
clip right there. He wasn't even sure that he
wanted to admit that he got the booster shot
because he was confused. Yes. Mm hmm. And then, of
course, he immediately had to go on the defensive
like, No, no, no, don't do that. Don't do this
small group of people over here. If you had owned
this from the beginning, again, I don't even care
if you took credit for things that weren't even
yours. If it meant people getting vaccinated,
getting the country, maybe back to normal,
stopping the death and destruction the virus is
causing. I would have been OK with that. There's
a lot of lies, obviously, that Trump has told over
the years that I'm really not happy about that
I dislike and I've spent hours refuting them
on my shows, even on this show here. But taking
credit for the vaccine. Sure, whatever, whatever
it takes at this point, to get conservatives
vaccinated, to get them boosted. And of course,
the remainder of the Democrats and everybody
else out there, we're all in this together. OK.
We have to come together here. And believe it
or not, for most of what Trump was saying there,
it almost appears that that's what he was trying
to do. Now we know he wasn't pulling one of those.
Everybody's got to come together and defeat this
moments. He was trying to take credit for what's
happening today. He's trying to take credit for
the fact that people are getting vaccinated.
Does he deserve credit for that? No, probably
not. But again, I'm okay if he tries to usurp
some of the credit. If it means getting more
people vaccinated right now. In Trump counties,
counties in the country that voted for Donald
Trump, which I'm sure we all know by now,
the death rate is three times higher from COVID
than the counties that voted for Joe Biden.
Conservatives are dropping dead from COVID
at a far greater rate than liberals are.
That's what that means, that's
what the science is telling us.
And for these Republicans out there to take
the opposite approach, which we're actually
going to talk about that in just a moment. But
Trump understands, I think, maybe to a degree
that you can't kill your base. I think Bill
O'Reilly, to a degree, again understands that.
I think some of the people at Fox News understand
that. You can't continue to let these people die
and still expect your conservative outlet or your
conservative cause or your conservative campaign
to be successful. You know, here in the state
of Florida, and I always like to use this as an
example. Elections, at least at the state level,
the last presidential election was not as close.
They're very close. Typically decided within
a few thousand or a couple 10000 votes.
Well, we've had 62000 people die of
COVID here in the state of Florida,
and again, the numbers are going back
up all over the country. They're rising
almost faster than anywhere else in the
country here in the state of Florida.
And again, it is affecting Republicans more than
it is affecting Democrats, because according
to the numbers, they're far less likely to have
been vaccinated and boosted than the Democrats.
So you're killing your base in a state down
here in Florida that could be decided the next
governor's race in 2022 could be decided
by ten thousand twenty thousand votes.
Well, you've sent that many conservatives
more than that to their graves.
So how are these people not waking up and
understanding that this isn't a winning
electoral strategy, you know, forget the
economic impacts, forget the human right,
the empathy aspect of it all. Think of
it from a purely political standpoint,
what do you have to gain from your
base dying before the next election?
We all know the answer to that. We
know that you have nothing to gain.
You're not going to win political
favor from people who are dead.
And again, I think at least to a small degree,
Trump understood that. And of course, he wants
all the credit. He wants the pandemic to end just
as much as everybody else, but he wants it to end
so that he can say, my administration
is really the one that ended it.
We put the vaccines on the fast track. We got
this done. We gave the money to Big Pharma.
They did this in nine months instead of five to 10
years, which is the typical timetable for getting
a vaccine ready in, approved and out there to the
public. He's right about that, believe it or not.
But it is a selfish reason. But at this point.
We may have to accept a little bit of selfishness
from these individuals if it means they get
vaccinated, right? We can do the fact checking
later. We can correct the misinformation
about who did what with the vaccines
at a later date, once everybody is protected. Once
we finally for real for good flatten the curve,
then we can have those discussions in the
meantime. If what it takes is letting Trump
go out there and try to take credit for the
vaccine in order to get conservatives to take it,
I am OK with that and I think a lot of people
also should be OK with this. It doesn't matter
which party is or isn't getting the vaccine when
you still have such a large part of the population
that hasn't even gotten a single dose yet. That's
a problem. It's going to allow for more mutations,
more infections, more overcrowded hospitals. And
more deaths. So at this point, we are in what I
consider to be a whatever it takes scenario. So
if it means Trump hogging some credit for the next
few months in order to get these conservatives
vaccinated, believe it or not, I'm OK with that.